[Music]
i was told not to be jealous of his
relationship with this person and not to
come between him and his family if he
required celery at every meal and he
chewed it with his mouth open and you
said hey babe the salary and he's like
celery stays don't get between me and my
vegetables then you would know i have a
choice to make
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
so guy that you're with us
it has been a chaotic
[Music]
wild month
[Music]
i hope you're doing all right hope
you're doing all right and hope you're
doing well i don't know if you've got
peace and if you don't have peace hope
you've got people that you are walking
alongside right now it's a messy messy
messy time
we'll be talking about some of that in
the coming shows but just know that
we're with you and walking alongside you
wherever you happen to find yourself
let's go to
not andrea andrea it's andre it's that
right andrea from san angelo texas
andrea uh how do i see it am i saying it
right you're saying it right you got it
andrea
yes sir
beautiful beautiful is that a family
name
um no actually it's not
dude good for your folks that's
fantastic all right so what's up well
after a bit of a hiatus i found myself
dating again this year
met a great guy really big in the family
but one of his family relationships has
me feeling a little bit uncomfortable
and honestly a bit jealous at times
and i'm wondering if i'm just
overreacting and overthinking the
situation or if there could legitimately
be some relationship red flags i need to
think about okay tell me more this is
you've piqued my interest this is
fascinating
well um so
uh we've been dating for a couple months
now the entire time i've known him due
to life situations um he's been living
with a particular family member and so
he lives with her and they work together
who is it mom or sister who is it
no i i i'm not gonna disclose that okay
okay um yeah i'd rather not put that out
there right now okay um it's not it's
not mom okay all right it's a younger
family member and um so there
so he lives with her and um works with
her they have similar lifestyles so they
spend all their time together they run
errands together and in general just
kind of do life together all the time
um and then
it's
it makes it a little strange because at
times and i'll call them and i'll say
hey what are you doing i get a lot of
the we answers well
we are here we are there we are doing
this and i'll say hey do you want to go
do something and he'll be like well let
me find out what we're doing tonight
and
he won't make you know he won't make
plans with me unless he's cleared it
with her first like he'll check in with
her and see what she's doing and i guess
make sure he's not missing out on
something i don't know but he'll clear
it with her first and on a couple
occasions when i've actually planned for
us to do things together he's invited
her along okay how how
how old is he
uh we're in our 40s how how old is the
she
she's also in her 40s okay she's a
little she's younger than he is
okay all right so my first thought was
he's 25 and she's 16 and he's just
trying to help out okay
so they're both 40s okay um
i mean so
i hesitate it sounds weird but i
hesitate to say i hesitate to say it's
wrong and
i i am particularly attuned
to
romantic partners who are jealous of
their siblings um relationships i don't
think that's fair and i use i usually
think that's pretty annoying um but
my any let me let me say this way
anytime i get a question like this my
first question is always back to
the one person that can
that i can communicate with which is you
and
have you sat down and had this
conversation with him
i have yes
how did that cover how did you enter
into that conversation and how did it go
um well i just approached him and said
um babe you know i i know our family
life are different but this is how this
particular relationship is making me
feel right now and i was told not to be
jealous of his relationship with this
person and not to come between him and
his family
okay and that was pretty much the end of
conversation so here here is a a hard
but beautiful truth you got
a boundary
a very very clear one
and the choice you have now is do i want
to live in this
situation that makes me feel
uncomfortable for whatever reason
if he always if he required celery at
every meal
and he chewed it with his mouth open so
loud
and you said hey i i i love you
would you call hey babe uh i love you
um
but the salary
it's got it's got like can we do gum and
he's like
celery stays don't get between me and my
vegetables
then you would know i have a choice to
make
can i fall deeper and madly in love
with
or can i not and some could and some
couldn't and so you've got to very clear
this is my relationship with
my family member this is how it's going
to be
and you will always be
an adjunct to that relationship
and so you're getting an answer whether
you like that answer or not or that
answer is brutal and hard i get
uh but yeah it sounds like you're in a
fortunate place often people don't get
answers and you sounds like you got one
so
you got that how'd that answer make you
feel
um
not very good honestly right um i makes
me feel like a kind of a third wheel
kind of like a an additive to his life
and not a primary focus yes
i think i mean sounds that sounds right
what i what i'm worried about you is
trying to
work your way into
becoming the primary focus
i don't know if it's a relationship this
is just a
situational relationship because i know
he came across some hard times a while
back and then didn't really have any
place to go so i ended up moving with
family
and so i guess as a part of me is
somewhat hopeful that maybe this is just
situational
and that if things change that this
relationship
dynamic could as well
but i don't know so when you talk to him
about it did he say
i know this is a little bit odd um
that i bring my
basically the same age um sibling or
whoever it is along with us cousin
whoever it is
on dates together
and that i have to run by all of my
social activities and romantic
activities by
this other woman who i'm related to that
i live with
i know that sounds weird this is a weird
moment in my life and i'm working
towards did you get that or did you get
this is the way this is and don't get
between it
kind of a little bit i say a little bit
of both because i've got the whole you
know this is the way it is don't get
between it
but i've also gotten the
you know hey this is just the way it is
right now
so i'm i'm getting some mixed messages
and i'm just gonna can i tell you i
don't think you are i don't think you
are
i think you really really want to take
the message you're getting and make it
like
turn it a certain way so you can absorb
it as just right now because i think
he's a great guy and i think you've been
alone for a while is that fair
yeah
and so
i don't know what your past dating
history looks like um and it sounds like
it's taking you a while to get back in
the game
you're worth more than what you got
right now
and if he was on the phone with me
here's what i would tell him
he is welcome to this relationship with
this other person but it's unfair it's
dishonorable to drag another human being
along as a toy
on this ride
if you're gonna date somebody and start
thinking about creating a new world with
them they become priority over your
relationship with your
your live-in relationship with your
sibling
you know what i mean
yeah i do
and
just for everybody listening who just
went what uh
also
if my
wife and her brother wanted to go on a
like a brother-sister trip a couple of
times a year i would celebrate that
i want them to have the greatest
relationship in the world
my sister and i do stuff together like
there should never be a weird thing
unless i make it weird you know what i
mean
yeah yeah totally well i love his family
i mean they're they're great people and
i love the fact he's very much into them
i think i think you like the idea of
being a part of this beautiful system
the one problem is you're not a part of
it you're outside of it
yeah you are not being asked into it
you're being told this is where you will
be
and i i hate that for you
but that appears to be the reality
um
here if i'm you here's my next step
here's my next step it's a very direct
i've thought about this and i'm not
interested in
a
furthering this relationship
if
another woman be it your mom your sister
your cousin
is going to be more important to you
than me
you're welcome to that but if that's the
case cut me loose or if that's the case
i'm going to head out and it's been an
honor getting to know you and to date
you
but i'm not gonna play second fiddle in
this relationship
and if he says no i'm ready to make you
first fiddle
and once a week him and his sister
first fiddle if he says that you
probably should run just run for the
hills you're gonna be my first fiddle
yeah actually i'm out i'm out that's
weird
um
but if he does say no no i'm ready to
make you first in my life
and i've been through some hard stuff
and i'm ready to shift
um
but me and my me and my sister my cousin
my mom whoever get together once a week
for a dinner or for breakfast or
whatever
celebrate that
celebrate that
help them grow in their relationship
but unfortunately doesn't sound like
where you're at
so it's like you've been given a very
clear boundary and you want it to be
something different and i want it for
you but it's not reality
one of the keys to being well is owning
and acknowledging reality
and you're worth more than what you got
right now
i hope you can look in the mirror and
see that
we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back
let's go to patrick in cleveland ohio
what's up patrick
hey dr john good to hear from you again
you too man so okay so catch me up you
called uh i guess several months ago and
we talked
some work struggles remind me of that
yes
yes sir we did we talked about how i was
uh battling you know being overwhelmed
with my career as well as trying to
balance the three bands i'm in oh yeah
yeah yeah okay did you quit one of the
bands
i haven't yet but i'm working on it what
a sucker dude
what a chump
you're one of those guys that calls for
wisdom you're like i'm not gonna do it
but that's cool no man i've taken
everything you said in the heart so
i know i've taken it into my heart i
haven't done any of it but that's cool
man
um so
as a part of that call you mentioned
something about your girlfriend i said
hey man that's a whole other call call
back another time and then you did which
is awesome so tell me about what's going
on
and i can give you another
round of wisdom that you'll just put
into your heart and then go on about
your day
no i'm gonna do it man you're not doing
it but go ahead
so basically my girlfriend and i have
been living together and dating for four
years now just north of four years and
she has every right and every reason to
want to take our relationship to the
next step i'm not denying that at all
and i give her every reason to but
you know i'm in this position where
i feel like everything going on in my
life and in my own mental
instability i feel like i'm just not
ready for that yet i feel like i'm not
ready to marry her i'm not sure if it's
what i should do if we're meant to be
together if i'm even fit for marriage at
this point in life or ever even then
break up with her and let her go man
but it's like
i then break up with her let her go
yeah okay
it's like i don't want to do that i
worry that if i do that i'm going to
make a huge mistake because i'm not sure
if if i'm just self-sabotaging and i do
this in any relationship i'm in 100 yes
yes and yes and then yes on top of that
the reason i just told you to break up
with her so i wanted to see your
reaction
okay um i think you'd be making a huge
mistake quite honestly
i do
um
you're playing family now
right you're playing married now
um so what you're trying to do is have
both things at the same time kind of
similar to trying to have three bands at
the same time
and work a full-time job but also keep
this little this little music thing you
have a
grade a
like nat flashing neon sign
fear
of going all in on something
and if you want to do that to your
career and to your other fellow
musicians great don't do this to your
girlfriend
i agree you know what i mean
i do absolutely
here's why i'm speaking directly to you
like this
because i'm you
i'm you the number of times i've taken a
job and within six months i'm already
applying out just to see what's out
there i don't feel comfortable i think
something's gonna be mean to me but
it's just putting two feet in the ground
and i didn't realize that i was dragging
my wife through that and i was
i didn't realize that i was dragging my
kids through that and i was and they
deserve better than that i deserve
better than that and the people i work
for deserve better than that all that to
say is this your issue is not my issue
your issues your issue
four years
is enough
make your decision and move on with your
life
it may be this
here's another thing
um i went skiing this weekend with some
friends
have you ever been skiing
waterskiing no okay
um your water skiing behind the boat
um it kicks a big way wake up right so
it splashes a lot of water behind you
and it creates a wave that you've got to
get on one side or the other of it
and if you're skiing and you find
yourself and you it's and you find oh no
and you're split you've got one leg
outside the wake and one leg in it
it's super unstable
and at any second you feel like you're
gonna face plant because you are and
usually you eventually face plant unless
you can get one way or the other out of
this thing you got to get back in the
wake or you got to get way outside of it
where the water is like glass okay
i wonder if a ton of your anxiousness
a ton of your feeling in ins like you're
you're feeling like you're uh have this
just profound instability
some of your mental health struggles if
you will
are because you ride the fence on
everything you're riding the wake on
everything
make a commitment man let me put it this
way what you're doing isn't working
try something else
try it for six months you can't try
marriage for six months but
um
try
quitting the bands
try what it's like to go all in on a
band
or two
tryouts like to go all in on your career
try what it's like to go all in on your
wife just commit i'm in she's it
this is it
why won't you do that why won't you give
yourself that peace being inside the
wake or outside man you're just riding
the worst part of this thing
it's like it's it's so hard to describe
but
um
you know growing up and i did touch on
this in the last time we talked but i
had an extremely unstable and unhealthy
upbringing my mom painted the worst
picture about women to me okay she
poisoned my head about women they're
this they're that they're gonna ruin
your dreams they're gonna ruin your life
don't let this happen you know she was
the mother of five boys with five boys
and it's just like she painted the worst
picture of women i've had tons of
girlfriends tons of intimate
relationships
and i almost feel more comfortable like
being with multiple different women and
starting something new and riding that
honeymoon high
than i do like being involved with one
person i feel more comfort and bad
patrick but look at your life
i know i know it's a disaster chaos it's
chaos yes
and so you can't tell
you can say that it's um
less scary initially
but it's killing you
it is and i don't want to be this way i
want to want to marry her i don't want
to lose her like i want to be in a
position where i want to run down that
aisle and not
here's how you get there patrick here's
how you get there choose to run down the
aisle there is no magical moment
there's not this moment you're gonna be
walking through a grocery store and all
of a sudden the lights are gonna shine
on her in the right way
you decide
i'm gonna run down this aisle
i am gonna go all in you've seen people
on stage who are timid players and they
they make for a terrible um
they make for a terrible show
because they won't commit to the music
and then having fun while they're up
there
is that fair
no absolutely yeah
you're waiting for something that will
never ever come and you're dragging
another poor woman through it don't do
that i know i don't want to i think you
deserve so much better i don't
need that don't reassurance
i know it's like i don't i don't i don't
i don't want to pee on the floor i just
don't wanna then don't go in the
bathroom
it's like that yeah i know
um
so i wanna ask you something recently
you know her and i have been seeing a
premarital therapist i wanted to get
some external insight on our
relationship and it was almost like
you know i wanted to hear what she would
say about about us or you know should
you be together or not
i had a couple one-on-one sessions with
this with this therapist and
she diagnosed me with a borderline
personality disorder now i don't know if
that's really a big deal or not but it
certainly does make a lot of sense
borderline personality disorder is one
of the most challenging
um
mental health disorders
very very hard
very very hard
i believe that i have that okay
definitely lines yeah
so you have to make a choice
of a life of volatile
explosions
and a trail of people who loved you and
who are also hurt because you melt them
or a choice
of
um and that's professional relationships
personal relationships or
you are going to put in hard work over
the next three to five years
um
of dbt and rebt like there is treatment
protocols for borderline personality
disorder it is very very challenging
you're gonna have to decide i'm gonna
pull the string on like you just
mentioned these emotional highs
and i'm going to learn to
um become one with my body and one with
my emotions and learn what these signals
mean versus what i feel like they mean
and you have to put that work in
what i'll tell you is there's healing on
the other side of that it's hard but
there's healing on the other side of it
and if i've also seen people who don't
deal with it and it is
a trail of pain
that's your choice man
yeah
i certainly am ready for the roller
coaster i can't live like this and i
know that i'll end up just
hitting the wall you know at some point
in life i'm proud i am now i'm proud of
you for that
thank you
um did your clinician offer you any
well let me say this number one
borderline personality disorder is
over diagnosed with regularity okay
so i would go sit down with a
licensed psychologist in your area
and let them know
that i've been diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder by a premarital
counselor
um
or a licensed a licensed
you know clinical therapist too and obc
is fine but i've been diagnosed
i'd like a full um diagnostic test on
this
and then i want some treatment options
moving forward and there should be a
good practitioner in your area
okay okay um if you decide i'm gonna get
very serious about healing
know you're in for one
hell of a ride it's hard okay
because you're having to relearn how you
experience the world people with
borderline personality disorder
experience separation as a flamethrower
they experience love and joy as a
carnival
and so it's it's learning to accept
these different versions of how your
body feels you have to re-learn how to
do it and it's hard um but it's also
incredible
okay okay
that can uh that can certainly explain
why i pretty much always self-sabotage
things and
does do those just that that is that
example of a carnival versus a
flamethrower does that make sense
oh yeah okay all right
um so
so
be about healing man
be about healing
um what's your girlfriend say about
being married to you
she wants nothing more than that it's
like
she understands this prognosis i'm
dealing with she wants to ride the ride
with me i guess i feel i feel guilt
almost like let her be an adult let her
be an adult i know she's a grown woman
let her be an adult
if she says i'm in it then you've won
the lottery my friend and she's in it
and then you have to look at her and say
i'll be in it too
now i did ask her one other thing i
wanted to ask her that
you know what if
we just
aren't meant to be together
and you're i don't buy that for this
there's no such thing as that
okay y'all can choose to not be together
you can choose to not be with her
but the meant to be together thing is is
hollywood fairy tale bullcrap
okay i believe you okay that makes that
make sense you've been with her for four
years y'all live together you know
you know the ups and the downs and the
sideways
okay
she's flying like a kite out there in
the wind
and she said she is um
willing to
ride the ride with you but she wants
some security and i once she wants to be
on the roller coaster with you but she
wants a seat belt
and she wants to know you're going to
stay on the roller coaster you're not
going to jump off
and that's super super fair
yeah absolutely or you can say i'm not
interested in riding
which that's fair for you too
it's the ride in both sides of the wake
man that you gotta you gotta quit
yeah is that fair
it is fair yeah
all right you're a brave guy you're a
brave guy what i would tell you is now
it's time for action if i'm you or if
you're my son or you're my brother or
you're a friend of mine
i would tell you go get a true
um
go get a true workup
okay if i truly have i want to know if
i've got a borderline personality
disorder diagnostic
not and again i'm not trying to
you know spit on your on your marriage
therapist but i want to go get somebody
who is proficient and skilled in that
and in the assessment and i'll see if
that's a true diagnosis
and
if it is
awesome that's fully you and there's
some extraordinary gifts that people
with borderline personality disorder
have
some incredible gifts how they see and
experience the world they're a blessing
and there's some intense healing that
has to happen too is that fair
yeah okay go be about it
go be about it man
and my hope is
um
my hope is the next time you call which
you will you're gonna call me back in a
few months
you're three months five months six
months into healing
[Music]
and you're calling to tell me hey we
broke up for good i made the choice she
made the choice we broke up for good or
we're engaged
not because we weren't waiting on some
some
you know hawk to land on the telephone
pole to be like you're supposed to be
together or some vampire to come y'all
just made adult choices we're in we are
all in and we're gonna ride this thing
together we're gonna do it
and know this
got borderline personality disorder
healing is heart
it's hard and it takes a long time
and it's worth it because i've seen the
other side of it it's beautiful it's
incredible
we'll be right
back hey john dolone here and people i'm
getting fired up it's finally warmer
outside and it's starting to stay light
longer and you should be spending more
time outside going for a run playing
with your kids at the park or just doing
a bunch of yard work i know that i'm
doing all those things but when you're
running hard you must remember to
recharge your body with a good night's
sleep and that starts with a quality
mattress like a dream cloud
dream cloud's combination of gel memory
foam and coil technology keeps you
comfortable all
night long and that means you go all out
all day because you're actually getting
solid restful sleep at night time right
now dream cloud is offering their
biggest deal ever exclusively for our
listeners when you buy a dream cloud
mattress you get 499
in sleep accessories plus an additional
250 discount that's 749 dollars in
accessories and savings start getting
the rest your body needs visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress and 749
in savings today
all right we are back let's take one
more call let's go to emily in fairview
tennessee what's up emily
hi dr john how are we doing
today's a good day how are you today is
a good day that's a fantastic way to say
that
fairview is one of my favorite places
that's fantastic man so what's up yeah i
like it out here
well um
my husband has been
close to suicide
four times in as many months
and my question for you is how do i find
peace
who man
that's a tough one so walk me back um
what happened four months ago that
started this
dominoes
well um
you know i think it started before then
he's
military veteran ptsd
pretty sure he's got depression anxiety
and we've we've been fighting for a long
time to try to get him some
mental health counseling therapy through
the va
and
took a long time to get that to happen
um took him actually driving out to a
bridge
to get that to happen through the va
and so they
he's had counseling
for a little while through them but it's
been very inconsistent they'll go like
two months between sessions um
anyway so so
what why
um
we have recently found someone else okay
that is not through the va okay that was
my this is a
this is a level one emergency
yeah and so i'm not waiting on them
anymore
yeah
um yeah i'm not waiting on them at all
um good for you so we gave up on that
that route good good and i know that
that adds another level of shame and
frustration and anger and rage to a
veteran
that the one group that sent him out now
doesn't want to do anything remotely
close to
provide the help and care that he needs
um right that's that's a whole other
level man i'm so sorry
um so
what happened four months ago that
that something so there was some
triggering event that said i'm just
gonna i'm i'm practicing this i'm
leading up to this
i i don't know what the trigger was okay
i don't know
man
so where is he now
um you know he's got good days and bad
days but
you know i think he's still in a dark
place and you know he's only started
with this this new therapist you know um
two weeks ago yeah so
he's still
i feel like he's fighting his dragon you
know and
he doesn't have any
tools
to fight it with right now he's fighting
with his bare hands gotcha is he there
would he talk to me
uh he's not home right now okay
i'd love it if he called in and if he
calls in we'll move him to the front of
the line okay
okay cool um
man breaks my heart
um
there's a lot so
do you have little ones
yeah we got a six-year-old and a
four-year-old of course you do
um how are they doing how much of this
are they absorbing
um
i don't know
they don't know what's going on um
the night that he drove out to the
bridge when he got back home and told me
what had happened
i i broke down and cried and it was my
six-year-old daughter who was like
patting me on the back and comforting me
and i was you know i couldn't breathe
but um so she you know
they know something's up probably
what kept what kept him
there what kept him on that bridge
what kept him off kept him on
kept him on yeah
um i don't know
we
the night that happened we were
having a normal
conversation it was a very like
we were talking about hey what day is
this happening what you know when are we
is this on friday or saturday kind of a
very
administrative type conversation
and all sudden he just said
why am i even here and just left
and later he said he he wasn't sure why
he was feeling that way
so okay
so
i would tell you
one of the cornerstones of
you've probably heard me say this on the
show but just to reiterate for everybody
listen and if we have new listeners
every cell in the human body has one job
and that's to get to tomorrow
and then to get to the next day and then
get to the next day
and to override the system
and jump off of a bridge or to shoot
yourself or to take your life to die by
suicide
it takes an
extraordinary amount of
resolve
more so than we think
it's just so foreign to every part of
our body
down to the cellular level right
and one of the chief suicideologists the
person who studies suicide that i have a
high respect for
suggests that it's such a hard thing to
get your body to do that when they look
back postmortem on people who have died
by suicide
there is often
a trail of practice attempts
driving out
cutting deeper and deeper being a little
bit more reckless with guns or getting
it out and looking at it and getting out
and holding it
and so what i would tell you is this and
i know that you know this i just want
you to hear me say it um
this is as though your house is on fire
and he's trapped inside and you and your
daughter you and your kids are out in
the front yard that's how serious this
is
okay um
if at all possible there should probably
be some sort of inpatient
the fact that he is seeing somebody
right now is a really great sign
and i would ask if i'm here's what i'm
gonna try to give you some some glimpses
of peace but your home is on fire and so
you're not gonna have peace in this
particular season right now and so i
want you to make peace with not having
peace for a minute okay
often the rage and anger and frustration
and
inability to sleep and move is because
we're expecting things to be still and
they're not
and so
expect things to be choppy right now
it's kind of like i was just talking
about skiing the other day
whenever a boat drives by and the wake
is coming i expect it to be really
really bumpy and then i can deal with
the bumps it's when i expect to be
smooth and all bump comes out of nowhere
and i eat it does that make sense
yeah okay so expect to be
there to be a limited amount of peace in
the next few however long okay
okay i would
ask if he's okay with it
if for your own
peace of mind if he would sign a release
so that you could call his counselor and
get an update
oh okay
and if he signs a release the therapist
is required to
if you call and say i just need to check
in and see what um what level of concern
you have for my husband's well-being
on a scale of one to ten you come up
with some sort of skill and you can tell
them i don't wanna know all the intimate
details i don't wanna know all of the
things
i just wanna know that you're okay and i
would love for you to sign it would give
me peace in my heart
another thing that would be huge is if
he would do this
if he he would
commit to
no talking
just hand holding or
i'm looking for skin on skin moments
okay and that may be hard with the kids
and all all the crazy you know
um
can we have some you call them sos
moments you can call them skin on skin
moments
and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna pester you
about where you feeling what do you
think i'm not gonna do that
that's gonna hold you
i want you to hold me
yeah okay
and what we're trying to do is call is
have your body go
a third thing if i were you
i would go see a counselor too
okay because you're in this too
yeah well i started i started uh seeing
someone through better help good good
for you as well
good for you good for you
um
the majority of people who die by
suicide do not want to be dead
they want their hurt to stop
yeah exactly
yeah and the majority of people who die
by suicide
have some sort of
ramp up to this process and so the fact
that one of the questions i would ask
have you ever tried before yep four
times in as many months
that to me is on top of combat service
on top of like you're giving me a you're
painting a picture of me of a very
volatile individual
okay yeah
yeah
i'm so sorry that you're here and i'll
just tell you he's really really lucky
to have you
well i'm lucky to have him too
i know but it's scary right
yeah has he made you a promise that
he'll call you
what do you mean
um there's been some some efficacy
concerns around this and what meaning
there's been some studies that say yay
or nay on this
um one thing that i still love
and it may it doesn't guarantee anything
um
but i would love it if you had a piece
of paper that you wrote and did it nice
and said this is a contract between you
and me i'm the one woman you said you
were gonna be here for
and i want you to promise
that you will never kill yourself
and that if you ever feel like it you
will call me or you will call somebody
okay and make him sign it and you sign
it
now there's some like i said there's
people who've done studies and say that
doesn't really do anything or some
people just sign it and then they go
ahead and do
it's not guaranteeing anything
but here's what it does it gives you and
him an intimate moment that says i'm
asking a covenant of you
to not leave me yes yeah
okay
and that might be a moment filled with
tears it might be a hard moment
um i think you can do all this in a
single conversation and then here's the
last one let me let me throw this one on
there
ask him
let's clear the entire deck
pretend we're meeting for the first time
what do you need from me
yeah okay what can i bring to the table
for you
is it silence is it quiet is it touch is
it
are you just so sick of the gluten-free
bagels that i'm always making like right
like like what what can i bring to the
table do we need to move
do you need to re-enlist like what are
the what do what do we need to do to
come to the table
and let him know i'm all in
the last last last one is this idea of
perceived burdensomeness
is the idea that
people who die by suicide over time
begin to feel like the world would be
better if i wasn't here
my kids would be better off if i wasn't
here
yeah
he's really prone to
shameful thoughts about himself that's
right just guilt yep does do you know of
things that happened overseas
uh yeah okay
that contribute to that
yeah okay
um that's hard it's hard to sit with and
sit and unwind do you have a couple of
veterans in your local community that
you have their numbers so you can reach
out to him that he can reach out to him
yeah he's well he's got a buddy he's not
local but he's got a buddy that he has
reached out to when he was feeling
suicidal before he needs some people in
fairview
okay or in lieber's fork area or in
franklin he needs some people local and
dixon okay
yeah he has he has local friends too but
i don't know that they're veterans
though
he needs some people who have been there
okay okay
and um he may say no and you can tell
them you you may not get them i'm
getting them i'm gonna reach out okay
and i'm gonna make this weird on all of
us
um
and i'd love for him to call if he'd be
willing to okay
okay i know he's fighting uh world war
iii in his in his head right now
and
i'm sorry that's going on for him i'm
sorry that's going on for your two
little ones and i'm sorry that's going
on for you
and if he happens to has a chance to
listen to this i need him to hear me say
the world will not be better off with
you not here
and
carrying the bricks of shame son set him
down
time to set him down
the heartbreaking part for you emily is
that he's the only one that can do that
for himself okay
have you made him a promise to never
call or never tell or anything like that
no um
he made me promise to tell people
good hey
gosh that's a brave man that's an
awesome guy
if you ever get a hint call everyone
call 9-1-1 every friend every pastor
everybody you know every time okay
okay promise yourself that okay
maybe when you ask him to sign the
wellness contract
you hand him on and say
anytime i'm calling in everybody
everybody
eat i'm gonna call so many people i'm
gonna call an idiot podcaster that's
what i'm gonna call
right
uh i'm gonna call everybody okay okay
emily we love you and you call anytime
we can help and if you can get him on
the phone with me i would love that too
okay
okay all right you're doing all the
right things and
man
if you are watching this
the world would not be better with you
not in it
[Music]
and if for a moment you think i just
need this to stop
remember this moment i'm sitting with
you
we're all sitting with you
reach out and make that call
reach out and make the call
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back
as we wrap up today's show man we almost
saw the return of the horse noise here
man those
suicide calls are tough suicide calls
are tough borderlines calls are tough
boyfriends who's
maybe sisters kind of girlfriendy those
are real tough
but lucky for me
we got the team
brought in the lyrics to
the famous dean lewis song if you've
heard of dean lewis you're better than
me because i have not i don't know who
that is
but hopefully the this person hopefully
old dean jams
hopefully old dean's not a terrible
human because then i'll get canceled for
what the song is called waves
the song is called waves and it goes
like this
there's a swelling storm and i'm caught
up in the middle of it all and it takes
control of the person that i thought i
was the boy i used to know but there's a
light in the dark and i feel it's warmth
in my hands in my heart but why can't i
hold on it comes and goes in waves it
always does always does we watch as our
young hearts fade into the flood
into the flood and it comes and it goes
and waves and it carries us away
it carries us right back here on the dr
john dolone's show we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode i feel
um portrayed
betrayed by god
and i'm very angry at him right now i
found the love of my life in germany
a week after we got married we found out
she was pregnant
two weeks after we got married we found
out that she had stage three
inflammatory breast cancer
she never expected to live very long
things continued on for eight years and
um this past
march she went to the hospital she never
made it out of the hospital i ended up
having to take her off the ventilator on
april the 7th
she was only 32 years old it's literally
the only thing i've ever asked god not
to do to me and and it's happened if you
were sitting with me right now
i'd give you a hug
and i would hold the hug past the time
when it was
awkward to when you could feel
my body telling your body that i love
you i'm sorry